what's your favorite food
pizza pizza it would make I mean that's
pizza's like even when it's bad as good
I was going to say that it's hard to
[__] up pizza facts California does a
good job
though they getting better though cuz I
remember like couple years ago I would
come out here and the would be
disgusting now this they they got some
decent spots out here me and my wife
always talk about it California's Pizza
is terrible it is because the spots that
the locals are like this [__] is great
they might have great like this is some
pizza absolutely and then you go to
these dude I'm in the Valley and this so
hard to find a spot that sells pizza and
wings together I'm like what kind of
like who raised y'all who open these
restaurants like why can't I get hot
wings W they got good pizza in Arizona
yeah actually you know like the number
one rated pizza restaurant in the United
States is in Arizona it's called
Pizzeria biano they actually did a
Netflix episode about it really yeah gas
I'm might have to go try that out bro
cuz I don't believe you no it's really
good it's not like a New York style it's
like a wood oven that's delicious oh so
good the margarita look it up pizzer
Bianco it's like ranked like it's always
in the top he knows he knows is the New
York water yeah it is same with the
bagels the New York water I've heard
that about the bagels Bagels [__]
Pizza it's it's the water is the water
supposed to be better in New York it is
absolutely you could drink the tap water
really absolutely oh [__] I didn't know
that yeah you can drink the tap water in
New York I always figured to be the
opposite n it's not I don't know I don't
know how they do it when I think of New
York water I think of the episode of
Seinfeld where Kramer swam in the was it
the River or the yeah those shits are
nasty yeah but con Island Cone Island is
disgusting I won't go I go in Coney
Island water once a year on New Year's
Day like the polar bear PL but I go in
that [__] with sneakers with Tims it's
[__] up the water it's not it's green
yeah you ever go party in like a or like
hang out in like a like what are the
like where the hton are and [__] where
they got all the [__] yeah yeah it's
the same water as col it's the same [__]
yeah yeah it's the same like it's just
more expensive houses yeah that's it
yeah still the same [__] water uh
what has been the most random moment
where you've kind of pinched yourself in
the last five well let's say three years
um where you're just like what the [__]
yeah not bro it happens a lot people I
meet a lot of celebrities that
are hyped to see me yeah like they hype
on they get like I'm I'm like oh [__]
that's this person like don't don't ever
disrespect me yo or some sometimes it's
ill when they be like oh I've been
loving your raps and like ghost face
when ghost face was like yo I've been a
fan of you was like the first battle rap
I really [__] [__] with wow you know
what I'm saying so I was like yo you
meet a lot of these people you think
they don't be watching they be watching
do you get free Nicks tickets
now Nicks ain't never give me not one
ticket bro really not one ticket [__]
the New York Knicks bro you gave them a
whole remix bro I gave them a
remix a whole [__] rally and cry bro
they did not do the right thing at all
at all they didn't even offer oh matter
of fact they didn't reach out I went I
did their C they reached out for me to
do their celebrity game I did it it was
like yo whatever whatever game you want
just let us know I just said I like
towards the end of last season I was
like all right I'm let me redeem these
tickets like give me a I don't care
what's the game makes don't don't
disrespect me and give me some [__]
seats I need court side or I'm not going
yeah every time my Nick hits a [__]
three bing bing bro they never got back
or they tried to hit me with the
[__] seats or have me try to do some
content for them yo give me these
[__] seats so I ain't doing [__] like
[__] out of here
man they've been disrespecting me for
Mad Seasons I'm a life I was a lifelong
Nick fan but not no more when I see how
they do business that [__] is disgusting
at least you guys have Brunson that's
nice I don't give a [__] who we got [__]
them [__] them go Nets facts I mean
Brooklyn go [__] sixes go [__]
Suns who gives a [__] I like that all I
care about is the Giants New York
football Giants bro smack the [__] out
the called do you like Daniel Jones no I
do he had a good year bro he beat the
Vikings in the playoffs yeah yeah he's
growing on me pause yeah and I think
Barkley's out of there though I think he
Wass to no he's back he probably does
but he's he's here this SE one year
[__] contract [__] idiots gave
Daniel Jones a 70 million whatever
seven-year contract they give Sequon no
[__] I just don't feel like you
should ever give anyone who played
football for Duke yeah facts that much
money facts like you played football
bought Duke yo it got to be some racial
[__] Bro the they be always they always
get white
quarterbacks I mean also they're [__]
over these running backs like Dalvin
cook they [__] he's on the Jets what
the [__] yo the Jets on the low got a
squad they got [__] they're going to
be nice what's his name s Gardner Aaron
Rogers Aaron Rogers bro but the Jets
always do that they always pick up a
dopee ass quarterback after his prime
yeah that's just picking up check is it
like a a tense rivalry between the
Giants and jets yeah I mean the Jets are
[__] they're terrible like the Mets
you know what I'm saying it takes a lot
of heart to Mets to be to be Jets or
Mets fans cuz you know they're not
winning no time soon Aaron roders with
[__] who was the um the cornerback
they got the a couple years ago Rivas
they don't do nothing with these [__]
stars they at the end of the day like if
you're a Jets Mets fan you probably
would forgive your wife wife for [__]
another Mane absolutely you probably
walked in your wife getting and you know
what you do you'd be like I've dealt
with my whole life hey hey guess what
I'm mad right now maybe next year but
I'm going to go walk it off all right
when I come back these guys better not
be here and my dinner better be ready at
least take a shower before bed damn go
Mets
go anyway yo so the album is out man
everybody should go support Rise of the
Silver back is out right now wherever
you listen to music if you [__] watch
this whole [__] and you don't go listen
to the [__]
album Bro [__] Your Life bro I hope
[__] choke on a dildo what's
your glass or rubber glass go break it
two front teeth yeah you know there some
[__] that put a glass dildo in like a
freezer that's some [__] wh
[__] got to be a ho to do that like I
remember like when I was like 19 I
opened this bitch's free freezer I was
at her crib in the middle of the night
and I opened her freezer and there was a
[__] dildo in there and I was like
like oh yeah it's it feels good like
when you when you freeze the glass
deildo I'm like that's like the glass
the the kid in the Christmas story when
he puts his tongue won't that happen to
the [__] yeah right that's a good
point wow it's my new
[__] yeah that'd be [__] up bro you'd
have a real uh that'd be a painful
penetration hey yo all right bro what we
getting at R of the silver back out now
bro where can people buy the merch FY l.
NC there's no.com people get confused
like oh there's no. net.com no it's
www.fl NC and if you're in New York come
by the fyl store and if well go by
[__] Zoomies go to Zoomies go to uh
con Island get you a Gizzy and go to the
store facts there it is man I appreciate
you pulling up brother always my guy
always NS hey what up man uh